she was the best person ever she was a
rock Life Soul of the party just an
amazing person not just to everybody she
was just 59 years old Linda Allen hurt
her knee and got successful surgery here
at this Hospital in Fife back in 2019.
it was the Aftercare where things went
badly wrong when Mom was admitted into
ianie she told him that she didn't take
naproxen and the anti-inflammatory drug
it was documented on her notes that she
no longer takes she was given it even
though our note said yes yes she was
given it yes I was just in complete
disbelief saying how has this possibly
happened just came in my broken need now
to the point like she's dying
an inquiry has now ruled Linda's death
could have been prevented after she was
given medication which within hours
reacted with a large stomach ulcer
causing cardiac arrest and multiple
organ failure do you believe this
Hospital killed your mum yes 100 yeah
100 percent and I think because our pain
score had went from 0 to 10 and we
didn't end sort of the statements and
things and still not being told then
that my mum was seriously ill she was
there alone with no family which I
really felt feel for her officials in
this inquiry say chances to detect
Linda's deteriorating condition were
missed and the care she received fell
well below the expected standards NHS
Fife has accepted a raft of
recommendations to avoid future deaths
on their watch I spoke to mum on the
phone whilst I am on holiday and she
told me and I said here you're gonna
have to say something because I know
what you like mum and she was like yeah
yeah I promise I said because if you
don't I'm gonna I'm gonna call the
hospital and again another regret I
didn't call the hospital I didn't call
but it's not easy was that one of the
last conversations that you had with
your mum yep
Connor Gillis Sky News